(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're asking the question,
well, I'm asking the question,
should I get back on Instagram?
Should I finally--
- You're still asking
that question?
- Get back on Instagram?
- I've been asking this
question for (sighs)
a number of years, and I
just thought this would be
a great forum to finally make a decision,
because I've been thinking about Instagram
a lot more lately.
It hasn't lost steam, you know?
- Oh you think it might be here to stay?
- You know the background
and I've asked you
to get into it but just how many years
have I been off Instagram?
- About six?
- Gosh.
It's been six years since
I've been on Instagram
and it's still happening.
I got family, friends, general loved ones
who are Instagramming it up.
I mean, I'm a digital
creator, for goodness sakes.
I just feel embarrassed
that I'm not on Instagram.
So I've been thinking about
it at a higher frequency
and I also think, end of last year,
beginning of this year, it's one of those,
maybe the new year is the time for me
to think about Instagramming
again, I don't know.
So I'm just saying, I've
been thinking about it
and Rhett, I just wanna ask you just
to help me think this
through so we don't have
to have another discussion about it.
Maybe at the end of this, the answer's no.
Shut up about it, just give
up even thinking about it.
- Barbara, get out of the trash.
You know, your dog sits.
- I love how you yelled into the mic
for Barbara to get out
of the trash because--
- She's got headphones on.
- She doesn't have headphones on.
She can't hear you better.
- Well here's the thing,
your dog sits nicely
in your lap.
My dog is just exploring
the territory around here.
I'm just hoping that she'll
learn everything she wants to
and sit down.
- They've had a big day.
Just hanging out in our office.
They had their hopes up that
it would be really exciting
hanging out at work
together and they realized,
oh, it's kinda boring.
Like our kids have done.
- Here's my perspective on this,
just to sort of, the
beginning of my perspective.
- And can you say something to them
if they could care less about
me getting on Instagram--
- That's what my perspective
is going to encompass.
- Great, 'cause I feel the need for that.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
In one sense, I would say,
this isn't like you're deciding
to start a side gig.
This isn't like you're
talking about doing something
that is going to in any real significant,
tangible way, alter your
lifestyle or the lifestyle
of anyone that you come
in close contact with.
You're talking about activate,
not even beginning for the first time
but activating a social media platform
that the majority of
people in the western world
probably already are on.
- Mm-hmm.
- And--
- I disagree with a lot of
what you've already said.
- Okay.
- And I'm prepared
to explain it later but keep going.
- So what I'm saying is,
I think that is sort of,
that's the perspective
that I bring to this
is that it really isn't a big deal.
- Just post a photo or don't.
- Just come back, but at the same time,
you know what, we talk
about it for an hour,
we can get a episode of
Ear Biscuits. (laughs)
- I've thought a lot about this.
I have lots of hopes, fears, concerns.
There's a lot wrapped up in this for me,
and I need to process it.
- I noticed.
- But I also think that
it's not just about me,
it might also be about you.
Or about loved ones of yours and their--
- You talking to me or
you talking to them?
- I'm talking to them.
- Oh.
- What's your relationship
with social media
and specifically,
does Instagram represent a threat
to your personal wellbeing?
I think that's a component of this.
And like I said--
- I have thoughts
about that as well.
- All right, well--
- For how it would relate to you.
- We can get into that, but--
- You want me to kind of
give a little background?
- Please do, please kinda
bring me and everybody else
up to speed on where we last left me,
did that come out right?
Where we left me last on Instagram.
- Well I'm gonna give
some full context here.
- Okay.
- I know it's a little strange
that I'm using a laptop to
access a Instagram account
but I have multiple tabs
open because you know,
I wanted to explore this in detail.
- All right.
- So you know,
it does make sense in my own brain.
Now, Link, you posted your first,
or at least the first
picture that is on your feed.
I'm assuming, does this strike
you as the first picture?
- [Link] This is my first picture, yeah.
- [Rhett] 'Cause some people start earlier
and then they go back and delete.
You didn't do that.
- I haven't done that.
I've done some deleting of other things
which I'll get to later.
- You posted on July 25th, 2013.
- Wow, 2013.
- So five and a half years
ago, not quite six years ago.
- This is when I joined.
- This is your first post ever.
I remember this day, we were shooting,
was this YouTube Rewind?
- YouTube Rewind, yeah, for
the Anaconda music video--
- Hold on but why did
you post that July 25th?
Was this like you
accessed this from your--
- I might have posted it
when Rewind came out or--
- Rewind doesn't come out
in the middle of the summer.
July.
- (chuckles) I don't know,
I thought you said January.
So yeah I don't know.
Maybe we were shooting it that early.
- Are you sure this was Rewind?
I think we went to--
- It was a YouTube set that
was built for people to shoot
different types of
things for their channels
so I was wrong about that.
This is just a jungle set
built at the YouTube Space
and we happened to be
there for another reason.
- Here's what I'll say,
this is a great start.
This was a great start
to your Instagram career.
- I'm holding a club and my caption is--
- We be clubbin'.
I mean it's got a built-in joke.
Some tongue-in-cheek, punny humor.
- Interesting location.
- The club is well-framed
in the foreground.
- You took the photo so don't--
- Oh yeah, Rhett really
framed the photo very well,
focused on the club which
brings all the attention
to the club which is the butt of the joke.
- Keep in mind the
listeners can't see this
so let's not dwell too
much on the picture itself.
- Okay, well no, I'm trying
to let you picture it
in your own mind.
- Okay.
- Now just for comparison sake,
and I'm the control group.
I'm the guy who is still
on Instagram, okay?
- Yeah.
You got a club picture?
- I started Instagram two and
a half years before you did.
Interestingly, November 10th, 2011.
Well that's not two and a half years.
That's a year and a half or almost.
(dog whining)
Barbara's now yelping, she's whining.
Bar, just listen.
Just sit down.
We're just having a conversation.
- Why is she staring at the door?
- She wants to leave.
Just lie down.
Nobody's out there.
- She's ignoring you.
She'd rather stare at a
wall than be with you.
- We'll see how long that lasts.
We might have to get
Jenna to come get her.
I posted a picture.
No caption.
I came out of the gate not hot at all.
No caption whatsoever.
- [Link] But a lot earlier than me, okay.
- And had a wigged picture.
Now I don't know exactly why at that point
when I made the decision
to get on Instagram,
you didn't, because typically when we--
- Because--
- We embark on things
like this, we typically do them together.
- It was a new thing and I'm like,
I don't wanna do another thing.
Another thing that will
probably fizzle out
when there have been some things
and they had just fizzled out.
I can't remember what they are.
- So it does take a
little bit more from you
to kinda get your--
- Yeah.
- Get your mojo up to the place
where you wanna actually participate.
- But I finally broke and I did it.
- And then you posted,
let me get out of this.
First of all I just will comment
that your next two photos were faces of--
- [Link] Sculptures.
- [Rhett] Like one's a Lego
sculpture and one is a series
of baby dolls put together to make a lion?
- Pretty crazy.
It's a mask made out of baby doll arms.
I think that was at a museum or something.
- It was an amazing Medusa
sculpture from your vacation
in the Exploratorium in San Fran.
You actually shortened San
Fran, you could have put SF.
You probably would do that now.
- So a vacation pic.
- So, is she scratching the door now?
That dog is just, it's like
she's being held captive.
Okay, and then, a handful
of posts later, I mean,
not more than 30 posts later,
it was November 30th,
so about two and a half years later.
No no no, it's the same year, it's 2013.
What?
- Same year.
- What, it's November 30th, 2013.
You didn't last a year?
It was from July to
November of the same year.
- I didn't even last a year.
- And interestingly,
your last post--
- From a mountaintop.
- It's like you're saying goodbye.
You know what I'm saying, it's
not even a picture of you.
It's just a picture of the sky.
And it's just like you're
like I'm going into the ether.
- Yeah and I got 32,000
likes on that thing.
That's pretty good, right?
- You have 32,000 likes on that
because it's your last post.
- Oh.
- I mean--
- How many followers do I have?
I don't even know that.
- You currently have 476,000 followers.
- Almost half a million followers.
How many do you have?
- Oh, thanks for asking.
First I had to scroll
through all my many posts.
Funny thing is is I don't
even post that often.
I have one--
- Whoa!
- Million--
- You got a million followers.
- No that's what happens when
you continue to participate.
- I'll be dag.
- I don't know the exact
number because it just says 1m.
- I don't have a
competitive bone in my body
so this is not even, this
is not resonating with me,
I'm just like surprised.
So you, you've doubled me but
maybe I could get competitive
and that could be
something to motivate me.
- But I will say that just
doing the math on this,
that I've definitely put in
more than twice the effort
and I'm still only
twice as many followers.
- Right.
- So you actually have done--
- But it's taken its toll.
- You were on for a year.
- I can look at you and tell.
I mean--
- I've aged.
Aged quite a bit.
- Your Instagramming habit
has taken its toll, man.
Look at me.
Look at how spry I look.
This is the delta.
You have half a million more
followers but you gon' die
a lot sooner than me if it
comes to natural causes.
- Well here's the thing.
I have 416 posts which is
not a lot over a period
of what we're going on, eight years.
You had 51, 51 posts, okay.
51, not too bad.
- Pretty good.
- But yeah that's where you left it
and we've talked a lot
about you coming back
and we've made a lot of
fun of your final photo
and we actually did a
recurring and by recurring,
I mean I think we did it twice, segment.
- We couldn't even keep doing that.
- On whatever season of
Good Mythical Morning
when we started making all those videos,
whenever that was.
- Yeah we started making the segments--
- Already forgotten.
- People were hating on
the segments and hating
on that particular segment
which was like a tongue-in-cheek bit
of like, what picture is gonna
bring me back on Instagram?
What am I gonna post
'cause I'm gonna come back.
I am determined to get back on Instagram.
Continue to help me out, guys.
I want you to tweet using
#linksperfectinstagram
with your suggestion of what my return
to Instagram should be.
- I believe in you.
Do it.
- Don't hold back.
And then the segment went
so poorly that I (chuckles)
it's like this is a sign
and I get back on Instagram.
And then I left it.
- And we were actually
at that time, we were
just building towards you
legitimately coming back.
- I thought I'd made a
decision to come back
and we were just gonna do
that bit in order to do it
but it never happened and
I just, I back pocketed it
and I suppressed it, and
it's just been something
that's just been lurking and lingering.
Oh gosh.
- Okay well,
we're gonna come back in
a second and we're going
to get behind, why it looms
so large in your mind.
What's the psychology?
- I have a list of problems with Instagram
that I'm gonna need you to address.
- Okay.
- And then if there's a way forward,
we're gonna have to
collaboratively find it
but we're gonna have to
navigate some problems
that I believe are common
to most anyone who is on
or considering being on Instagram.
- Okay and while I take my dog out of here
'cause she obviously
doesn't wanna be here,
you can tell people where
they can get these mugs.
- Okay.
Mythical.store is the place to get
the official Ear Biscuit mug.
Check it out, it's speckled.
It's freckled like Kesha in the summer.
You know, get yours now.
I love freckles.
I think it's great.
So much so that I requested
that they be on this mug.
Get this one alone, get it with the LTAT
and the official Good
Mythical Morning mugs.
They all work together
as a set or separately.
There's lots of other stuff
over there at Mythical.store
so go on over there.
Rep your squad and that's
us, the Mythical squad.
Mythical.store.
And we're back.
- Now in the time that it
took me to take Barbara out,
she started her own Instagram account.
- It's that easy.
- It's really,
it's that easy, Link.
- Well it's probably even
easier to get back on
but it's not without its pitfalls.
I think the first thing psychologically,
the problem that I have
with Instagram is that
I think it traps people into seeming,
or actually becoming or being
self-important or braggy.
It traps people into seeming
like they're bragging
or humble bragging.
Part and parcel with any
post on social media,
not just Instagram I think, at its core,
I just, there's this implied assumption,
and I could be wrong about this.
This is just how I feel about it, okay,
that an implied assumption
that who I am or what I'm doing
or the specifics of what I'm sharing,
that people will be
interested in it, you know,
so it's hey, look at me.
I met a celebrity.
I ate a cannoli.
- Mm.
- I am at a cool party.
Isn't my baby or my dog cute?
- Yes, yes.
She is actually.
- It just seems like you're
sending a message that
I think I'm good looking enough to assume
that you would enjoy looking at a picture
that I took of my own face.
They call that a selfie.
- Yeah.
- You know, so it's, there's
this self-consciousness
that wells up at the moment I'm thinking
about anything I'm gonna post.
- It doesn't have to be a selfie.
Sometimes you can hire a
professional photographer
to take a picture of you in
a striking fruit-themed suit
on the shores of Mexico.
- Now I ain't trying to pick on you.
I'm just talking about myself here
and what goes through my mind.
- I'm proud of that, I'm
proud of every photo.
Especially proud of that one (chuckles).
Okay I see what you're saying.
And so--
- Isn't that the underlying,
like the core message of
anything that you post is
I assume that you're
interested in me or this thing
that I'm posting.
- Well yeah but I have
a number, your perspective is not wrong.
Because that is, especially
for a lot of people,
maybe the majority of people,
sort of the subtext of Instagram.
- Uh-huh.
- But,
you say this as someone who
makes their living on YouTube.
- Yeah there's some seeming
irony in that, right?
Seems like it's not adding up.
Yeah, it seems like my
job is, hey, look at me!
Every day, go to YouTube
and look at my face
along with your face and laugh at it.
Isn't what I'm doing funny?
Isn't what I'm doing interesting?
Look at me, look at me, is it really--
- So while I--
- I assume that you want
to look at what we've planned.
- Yeah.
- But it feels different
because I feel like
what we're saying with
everything we create,
Good Mythical Morning, the top example is,
I feel like the underlying message is
I assume that you will enjoy
what we've decided to make.
Now it just happens to
feature my face prominently,
sometimes eating and gagging on things
and I understand that--
- I understand there is
a slight distinction there.
I get that.
- It's not look at me,
it's be entertained by what we've created
or be entertained by me.
- Which leads to my second point which is
you can have an Instagram
account that operates
on a different principle.
Lots of people do it, in fact, a number
of Instagram accounts that
I'm going to recommend to you
to follow, and maybe all of
them, are not personality-based.
So--
- Okay go ahead.
- So what I'm saying is that
that's one way to see Instagram.
Some people, we talked about this before.
I think I, and I don't
know if I've held to this,
but I established, I
pulled it out of my butt
as I always do, some ratio
that I thought was appropriate
for selfies to pictures
of things on Instagram.
And I think I said something like 20%.
Now, everyone will tell you,
every analytics person
will tell you that pictures
of your face are going to perform the best
and get the most followers.
So once you get into this place where
you do wanna get more followers,
everything sort of pushes
you in the direction
of taking pictures of yourself.
But you don't have to do that.
You could take pictures of
things, I mean your last picture
is a picture of the sky, the mountains.
You can just be the sky and mountains man.
So I don't necessarily think that
it has to be all about
you, but even if it is,
the way that I see Instagram is,
you know how like when you're
in a hotel in the city,
like you're in a hotel in New York.
- Mm-hmm.
- And if you're like me--
- Oh I've been in a hotel in New York.
- And you're in a high-rise hotel.
- Oh high rising it.
- And you go to the window
and you do what at night?
- Look out of it.
- And what are you looking at?
- The city.
- You're looking at what?
- Streets.
- No there's a building across the street
and there's what in the building?
- Oh I'm looking straight across?
- Yeah.
- A naked couple.
- Well I did see--
- I've actually never looked across.
I always think that.
I'm like wow, there's another
high rise building right there
and that's an apartment.
I'm gonna look across there
and I'm gonna see naked people.
But I never have.
I keep looking.
- Hold on.
But hold on but--
- Never happened.
- Don't you remember
the time that me and you
and Stevie and all of
our significant others
were together on a balcony--
- Yeah okay.
- In Manhattan.
And then we looked across to
the apartment across from us
and there were people doing
something and it took us
about 10 minutes to figure out
they were playing corn hole--
- Indoors.
- Inside.
- Yeah but it was not easy to figure out
'cause it was actually further away.
It was like, are they bowling?
Are they doing charades?
- Yeah yeah.
- They are playing indoor corn hole.
What desperate--
- And actually--
- Situation.
- And actually,
that fits perfectly into the way
that I see what Instagram is.
- You're gonna have to explain this.
- Instagram is--
- 'Cause looking
at naked people, I don't think
you can do that on Instagram.
- No you can't.
Female nipples, you can't
look at female nipples
but you can look at male
nipples all you want
because male nipples are dysfunctional.
- Okay, I'll need to write that down.
- But in fact, some, there was a--
- Let's not get off on a nipple tangent.
- Well I'm just saying,
there's a woman that took
male nipple pasties
and put them over her own nipples--
- Okay.
- As a way to say,
why, what's the big freakin' difference
between the two nipples?
And I think, I haven't--
- How'd that go over?
- I don't know.
I don't really know the story.
- Okay well I'm glad you
told the first half of it.
- (chuckles) But it was a little protest.
- Explain to me how
you're seeing Instagram
through the lens of
people playing corn hole
in an adjacent high-rise building?
- Anyone who has their window open
and is doing something in
an apartment or a hotel
in New York City is basically saying,
take a look at what I'm
doing right now, right?
And so that's why I don't
feel weird about just like,
and it's not like I'm
looking over there trying
to find something, it's just like,
I feel like I'm in a movie sometimes
and I'm looking across and oh,
and it's just like when Letterman
used to call that woman.
He would look across his office
and he would see the woman
and she was in the window.
- She was working.
- It's a real woman
and they ended up having like a long--
- Friendship.
- Term friendship.
I think that Instagram
is like your window,
your curated window to the world.
It's like saying, I'm
doing this right now.
I'm playing corn hole
right now and I want,
and I don't care who knows.
In fact, my friends who
know which window I live in,
who know which apartment,
if they wanna see me playing corn hole,
it'd be cool for them to take a peek
into my life at this point.
- Okay.
- And you can open the window
and show what you wanna show
within certain guidelines
and you can close the window.
- So you're saying it's not
begging for them to look.
- No.
- You're not flashing
the lights and yelling across the way,
"Playing corn hole over here
if you wanna look this way!"
It's more just like,
hey, the shades are up.
I'm throwing the corn
bag, look if you want.
It's up to you, take it or leave it.
- And I also think that there is--
- But it's not please,
please look at this.
- It is for a lot of people.
It is for a lot of people and
it is for me at times, right?
Like, there are people who
purposely post pictures
of themselves that are from
bad angles or they look bad
because they're trying
to counteract exactly
the general subtext that
you're talking about.
They'll take like a weird
picture of themselves.
- Oh they'll swing the pendulum to ugly.
- And I think that that is totally fine
and kudos to those people.
But see again, they have the
power to make that decision
and to show to the
world what they want to.
If your fear is that you're
gonna seem like a braggy Daddy
if you start Instagramming, well then,
approach Instagram in a different way.
- And I think that the first
different way that comes
to my mind leads to my second problem.
And that's because now,
it's not just pictures
but it's also stories.
And there's a whole lot of functionality,
I mean we do stories through
the Rhett and Link account
whenever we're out and about
doing something work-related
or yeah, just having an adventure.
But I think well if I'm
just not gonna post pictures
of myself, and be really
self-conscious about it,
then I need to be entertaining
and I need to make this a creative outlet
and it becomes like work.
It literally becomes work.
And to me, that is the second problem.
I went on, well here's the thing.
I would get into bed and
Christy's on her phone
and I'm on my phone and I've
started looking at Reddit
and I'm very entertained by that
and I'll fall asleep
to Reddit on my phone.
I think it's healthy.
But I look over at Christy
and she's laughing and like,
she's looking at one of our
mutual friends' Instagram feeds
and this particular person, we
just really enjoy his stories
and what he's posting and like
the way that he says things
and it's just, I love it.
It just makes me happy,
like seeing this person's
stories that is just a friend.
And like, I'm looking
over Christy's shoulder
and we're just like having a
blast looking through the feed
and then I realize, and she
wants to get to something else
and I'm like no no no,
go further, go further.
And she's like, I wanna look at this.
And I'm like you know what,
I have Instagram on my phone.
I can look at this on my phone right now.
There are no barriers to me doing that.
And then I pull out my
phone and I open it up
and it's the first time I'd
opened Instagram in five years.
And I look at it and I'm like,
my whole feed is just
populated with of course people
that I follow, right,
and only those people.
That's how it works, right?
- Well that particular,
yeah yeah, the feed.
- And--
- You can go to explore
and you can see other stuff but yeah.
- I'm looking at it and I'm realizing,
everything in my feed is YouTubers.
And then I go to the
who am I following tab
and I was following like 111 people.
And the vast, vast, vast
majority of those people
were all YouTubers, like the
moment I got on Instagram
way back then and posted
that club picture,
I just went on and started
following YouTubers.
Once you follow one or two
it's like they suggest you,
and so now I was just all of a sudden,
I experience just an avalanche
of anxiety that like,
oh wow, what are all these people doing?
It became this anxiety
of competition and comparison,
which I think is a general problem
with a lot of people on Instagram, right,
just there's an anxiety
of competition and comparison
and is my life as
interesting as this person?
Is my face as cool
looking as this person's?
Is my so and so, is my dog, you know,
hairy in the right places?
So you get into all that.
But for me, it's--
- I don't think anybody
is worried about that.
- Oh my gosh, what are all
these other YouTubers doing
that I feel like I should have been doing
for the past five years?
Became a business thing
and I totally forgot about
looking at our friends' Instagram stories.
And I was like, you know
what, this makes me mad.
And if I'm ever gonna
get back on this thing,
this is the problem and I
started clicking unfollow.
Unfollow, I clicked unfollow.
- This explains--
- 111 times.
- Because--
- I unfollowed,
'cause it was like the vast majority,
it just left a handful of
people and I was like screw it.
I'm gonna unfollow them too.
I unfollowed you.
- It was weird.
It was weird.
- It felt good.
It felt healthy, it felt like
the right thing for me to do.
- It felt good to go on
your Instagram account
that you don't use and unfollow everyone?
- Yes.
- You might need
to see a therapist.
(chuckles)
- Yeah and I am right
now and you're as close
as we're getting at this point.
But yeah--
- And I can say that
just before you think I'm
making fun of mental health
because I do see a therapist, okay?
- And I do think that
there's a therapeutic,
absolutely, there is something
that if I was talking
to a therapist instead of you, we'd be--
- I do think there's--
- It's a great thing for me
to talk to a therapist about.
- Something to crack open here
because--
- Yes.
- Your concerns are all valid, right?
The first thing you
mentioned about feeling like
this is all about being self-absorbed.
I could meet someone
who, I could have a friend who wasn't you
who wasn't an entertainer in any way
and they would be like,
I'm not on Instagram
because I feel like it just makes me think
about myself too much and it's superficial
and it feeds into a part of
me that I don't wanna feed.
And I'd be like, I respect that, man.
That's cool.
- Mm-hmm.
- So that's a valid thing.
Now my counter to that, I've
already stated it is that,
well you live a self-absorbed,
self-promoting life already.
- Thank you.
- And hopefully,
I think part of being
a healthy entertainer
is separating, this isn't easy.
This is easier said than done,
separating your self-worth
from people's perception of you and so,
I think that's kinda the way that I see
Instagram at this point
and hopefully bypass
at least some of that.
Obviously I still worry
about what people think of me
and that's why I post the watermelon pic
and the best pic of the bunch, right?
But I also know--
- Can I just say--
- And for me,
let me finish, for me, I'm posting that...
The pie chart of reasons for why
I posted the watermelon pic,
the majority, I truly believe this,
is because I think that
it is entertaining.
I think people will get a laugh
or people will get something.
And the way that I consume Instagram,
I will be contributing to it.
I read Yelp reviews, I
don't write Yelp reviews.
I take but I don't give.
But on Instagram, I take and I give.
I'm receiving the feeds and
I'm feeding into the feed
and I'm doing it because I
feel like I'm giving somebody
something that they can
enjoy on some level,
giving them insight into
my life and something
that I think is worthy of showing people.
I'm opening the window and saying,
"Hey we're playing corn hole today."
I don't post a whole lot.
So I think you can overcome that.
- But with that, I mean the
thing that I need to overcome is
I don't think I could ever post
that watermelon swimsuit photo shoot
because I would be afraid that
it would be misinterpreted
as oh I think I look great in
this watermelon bathing suit.
Under the guise of I think that it's funny
but people are just gonna
say that I look good in it.
- Yeah but that, but then--
- So then I'm concerned about,
I don't want people to dictate
what I feel about myself
but I'm afraid--
- When you make a decision
to wear the clothes that you wear on,
the clothes that you wear every day.
Are you like, nah man, I wear what I wear
'cause it makes me feel good.
If you wore what you wore
'cause it made you feel good,
you'd wear sweats all the time.
You make a decision to put clothes on
because it's external, man.
It shapes people's perception of you.
And then when you make a
decision to be on camera--
- I think that's one thing but
when you're posting a photo
on Instagram it kinda,
the number of reasons,
the number of potential motives
that someone could guess
shrink a lot more than the number
of motives associated
with what you're wearing
when you're just walking around town.
- But anything that you do,
I think you're making
a distinction between
showing a picture or
showing a slice of your life
and then what you do every single day
which is entertain people
and you are saying,
I think I've got something
interesting to say.
interesting to show you.
If me and you are going
and doing a concert,
it's like, we think
we're interesting enough
for you to buy a ticket
to come and see us.
We even think we're interesting enough
for 100 or 200 people
to pay even more money
to come just to get a picture with us.
- Mm-hmm.
- This is an incredibly self-focused,
self-promoting mentality
that we already adopt as an entertainer.
What I'm saying is that you of all people
should be able to make that transition.
Like I said, if you
were just somebody who,
if you were just, you know, a banker.
I got lots of banker friends.
And you were like, eh, I don't like that.
I don't like to be the
center of attention.
I don't like to dance on the dance floor
in front of everybody.
I don't like to tell
stories about my life.
But you like to do all those things.
You love to tell stories.
- You don't like
to tell stories about your life?
- No I'm saying if a
banker said that to me--
- Oh, oh.
- You lost my analogy.
If a banker said that
to me, and he was like,
and so that's why I don't do Instagram.
But you love to tell stories.
- Yes.
- You love to dance.
You love to be the center of attention
in the same way that I do,
maybe even more so than me
in all kinds of life situations.
- But I like to--
- But then you're saying
that all of a sudden--
- But I like to craft it
as a thing.
So then, that is my second barrier.
- But you can craft it perfectly.
- But that takes work.
- You can open the window
for a second.
- Right but that takes,
so that's the second
point is it takes the work
of how do I craft this, it's
the reason why I don't tweet
is 'cause like--
- Now this is interesting.
- I'm like is this funny enough?
Like, I gotta come up
with something funny.
There's a pressure of
performance when I just need
to like zone out or like take it easy.
- Yeah I completely relate to this.
- So I wanna find a way
forward that is not,
I don't want it to seem like look at me,
and I don't want it to seem like work
where I've said, hey, this
is not about looking at me,
this is about, and this is also not about
look at what I've come
up with to entertain you.
'Cause that's too much
work and then I like,
I just don't wanna add another place
where I gotta come up with that.
- So on the Twitter front--
- Those are my two problems.
Those are my two barriers to
getting back on Instagram.
- Do you feel like we've
addressed the first one?
What I'm trying to say
is you're not wrong,
but you've made an
unnecessary distinction.
You've cordoned off this area of Instagram
and said that this is somehow different
when what I'm saying
is that so many aspects
of your personal and
public life is already
about look at me.
Why not just throw one more into,
and do it in a healthy way.
If it is gonna make
you more self-absorbed,
then don't do it but what I'm saying is
I don't think it will.
I think that you're
already the correct amount
of self-absorbed that it
takes to be an entertainer
but not so self-absorbed that you become
a self-destructive entertainer.
- Yeah I do not think
that me posting pictures
on Instagram is going to
negatively impact me psychologically.
- Okay.
- I just think it's--
- It's a hangup.
- I don't wanna be thought
of as a guy who thinks
that you wanna look at him.
- Okay.
- I wanna be thought
as the guy that makes you,
that thinks you want to laugh
with or at him.
- But if you were the
first person on Earth
to be thinking about Instagram,
but everyone has an Instagram account.
Every single person that you
know intimately (chuckles),
you know well.
- Yeah.
- Has an Instagram account.
So you're in good company.
Doesn't make you weird or self-absorbed.
- Yeah and maybe I just don't take,
maybe I just won't take selfies.
- Sure well you can do, you
remember Casey Neistat came up
with that company, that app--
- Beme.
- Beme and it was all about
what you were seeing.
That worked well. (laughing)
(mutters)
- It didn't work.
- I think it actually worked
very well for Casey.
In the long run it didn't work for,
I guess CNN bought it but I
think the reason it didn't work
is because well I don't
think that's what people,
people are not necessarily just interested
in what you're seeing,
they're kinda interested
in seeing you, so anyway.
- I'm motivated to get back on because,
you know, my kids are on there.
It's like, I wanna be
able to spy on my kids.
- Let's get into that but I don't wanna,
I wanna address your second
point which I think is,
I relate to your second point.
I relate to both of your points.
The first point I feel like
I just bypass personally
because I was like, I don't
see why this is any different
than anything else I do.
Second point of it feeling
like work I really relate to.
I especially, 'cause first of all,
I don't post a lot,
at all.
- Yeah.
- My frequency is like
a photo a week, if that.
And my stories, well I'm
starting to do a little bit more.
Well I'll get into that in a second.
But Twitter, as a point of comparison,
you know I follow different comedians
and I see what they tweet
and it makes me mad.
Because I'm like, you know what--
- 'Cause you hate comedy.
- I do.
I feel like I do a lot of things well
and I usually can kind of
set my mind on something
and figure it out.
- Yeah.
- But and I actually fancy
myself a pretty good writer.
- You are a good writer.
- And I actually fancy myself
a pretty good joke writer.
Jokes in the context of a script.
What I cannot really do well is joke tweet
in the way that some of
these comedians can--
- I definitely can't.
- One of my favorite accounts,
Megan Amram, Ahm-ram,
however you say her last name.
And she's a writer here in town.
Like she just had a tweet
that was R.I.P. 2018.
2018 to 2018.
I was just like, that is so good.
And then I was looking in her feed
and she tweeted something like,
you ever wonder if all of
our muscles have the ability
to taste but the tongue is
the only one we put food on?
(chuckles)
And again, I'm just like, man.
- She better be good at it
'cause she is a writer, period.
- I know, that is what she does.
But I assume that she's also--
- Maybe I shouldn't try
to make you feel better.
So what have you decided,
that you're not good at it?
- Well, I oscillate, man,
when it comes to Twitter.
I think to myself, I think
the way forward for me
with Twitter is just, don't
put pressure on yourself.
See Twitter as an extension of your brain.
Again, it's like, it's this
thing where you can occasionally
just open it up and share a thought.
Sometimes it's serious,
sometimes it's observational,
sometimes it's funny, sometimes
you're definitely trying
to make a very specific
joke about something.
Maybe you're responding to somebody.
But I feel like I have a
similar hangup with Twitter
because I feel like I am
known as a funny person
so therefore I better
have a funny Twitter.
But also because it takes me time
to sit and think, I'm working
on a lot of other things
and contributing creatively
to a lot of other things
so I kinda feel like I
have a limited amount
of creative energy--
- And you know
that's how I think, yeah.
- If I'm funneling it into Twitter.
But with Instagram,
because it's not, it's not
curated in the same way.
Tweets are like, I have
to formulate a thought.
It's more work than like, I am
in this situation right now.
I could take a picture of it.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah I feel like
I could be better at
Instagram than Twitter.
And I think I'm done with tweeting.
I think Twitter to me,
especially if you succeed
at getting me back on Instagram,
this entirely up to you.
Then Twitter to me is just gonna becoming
interaction with people
who are tweeting at me,
so it's conversational.
Because I'm on the app 'cause
it's a news source for me.
I look at the moments and it's a fun way
to kinda get the news.
- It's a global conversation around--
- And then with one click over--
- Curated down to the people
that you wanna hear from.
- Because I follow so many,
I had the automatic re-follow
on Twitter so every fan who
followed me for like years
and you, we automatically
followed them back.
So that is useless to me now, honestly.
- I unfollowed a lot of people years ago.
- I don't do that so my
feed, it has so many people
just tweeting about their
own lives that like,
I can look at the @s where
people wanna talk to me
or talk about me.
- Or go to moments.
- Replies and I got to moments but,
so I'm giving up on trying
to tweet something funny.
I don't like to write in that way.
So it is opening a little margin
for Instagram if you succeed.
- Well and I think that my
philosophy towards Twitter
is becoming, I'm not gonna feel pressure.
If I have something, I'm like,
oh that would make a good
tweet, well just tweet it
without really scrutinizing
it and thinking too much.
But I'm using Twitter
as an example because
that sort of stage fright
that accompanies Twitter,
it doesn't translate to Instagram for me.
- I get that.
I don't think it would for me either,
unless I'm, I don't know, I
guess I said that it would.
If I can let go, I just
need to find a middle ground
of how I look at it where
it's not, all right,
I am going to do something
that's like a story video
that's gonna be entertaining.
I'm gonna make a little show for ya here.
Or like, I'm gonna post
this picture and I gotta see
how many likes it's gonna
get or something like that.
If it could become a
genuinely fun outlet for me,
like the way that I'm on
Reddit, I really enjoy it.
The way that I use Twitter,
I'm actually starting
to enjoy now once I let go of okay,
I've got to tweet something funny.
To me, the question is--
- Yeah but,
you just use both of those.
You're just using, you're
just sucking the life
out of both of those platforms
without contributing.
Which I do the same thing with Reddit.
I don't have a, I think I
have an old Reddit account
but I can't even log into it.
- Well is there another way
forward for how I could interact
with Instagram in terms of how I post--
- Lower the threshold.
- And what I consume
that makes it fun for me.
- Lower the threshold.
- Threshold of--
- What qualifies as
an interesting post.
I think I need to do the same thing
because I'm over here in lean,
not a lot of stuff going on
on Instagram land because I'm just like,
I don't think anything interesting.
I mean I think the thing
that people don't understand,
well maybe they do, is that,
sure we may do these ridiculous,
notable, Instagram-worthy
things on our show
but that's our show and then
when we're not doing that,
we're pretty much just
sitting around working
and developing things and then I go home
and that's why a lot of times,
my Instagram story will just be my dog
because that's who I see. (chuckles)
When I walk through the door and so--
- Well my dog's already
got an Instagram account.
I just haven't, I've also felt like,
I don't wanna tell anybody about it
'cause like, Lily posts stuff on it.
- Well she posts stuff
about the dog though.
- And I'm like, I just felt like,
if something's gonna get
posted and there's gonna be,
somebody's gonna find out
where I live or something.
I'm very concerned about that.
- Well, I think your kids
are probably actually
more equipped at managing
that than we are.
- Well I wouldn't know
'cause I'm not following them
on Instagram so that's the other thing.
Like I said, I need to
not spy but I need to,
turns out if I'm gonna have
a meaningful relationship
with my kids, a good
piece of that pie needs
to happen over Instagram.
- Yeah but the thing you
don't understand is that
you're assuming that you'd know
about all their Instagram accounts.
Just give up on that for a second.
Let me just lay out the
reality of the situation
with the teens, the youth
and their Instagrams.
They have more than one and
the one that you know about
is not the one that they communicate with.
- What?
- Yes, man.
- A Finstagram, that's what that is.
- Well, you sound like
you know more than me.
- A fake Instagram, I've heard about that.
- Yeah so they have an Instagram account
because Instagram makes it so easy
to just add multiple accounts
and switch between them.
So you have your Instagram
account that your parents follow
that you comment on publicly,
but then you've got another
Instagram account which,
and they're both private.
- There's a real Instagram
and there's a fake Instagram
and I think the fake Instagram,
I don't know which is which, but--
- Whichever one that you know about--
- Well my kids aren't
allowed to have that.
- Okay so you're gonna grab their phone
and look and see if they got it?
Because that's how they
communicate with each other.
They don't, you know,
for the longest time,
I was like, I remember
Locke was planning a party
for his birthday and the way
that all the communication
was happening was over Instagram.
I was like, this is how
you guys use Instagram?
Why don't you just text everybody?
He's like, "Dad, we don't do that."
(chuckles) I think that they do text
and I think he does
text with some friends,
but they use the apps to
communicate with each other
quite a bit and they're
not gonna use the account
that you know about.
You know, maybe they are.
You can't control them, man, just let go.
Let 'em be the youth.
(Link sputters)
But--
(Link chuckles)
- Okay.
- So but I feel like we
still haven't addressed
your second point.
To tie a bow on that--
- I need to find a way
forward that's not like work.
- Performance anxiety.
- Yeah.
- That you associate with this.
I relate to that and I
kinda have the same thing.
But I just, first of all--
- You're just saying don't
care, just flip a switch
and don't care.
- Just don't care.
I think your account would
be really interesting.
Link not caring is pretty entertaining
as we have demonstrated.
- Hmm.
I never thought about that.
- As a career.
- Well that's an interesting
point 'cause, I mean--
- Link overthinking has
never been entertaining.
- That's true.
You're exactly right.
- Yeah.
- And that's all I've been doing, man.
- In fact, let's think of all the things
that Link overthinking things has led to.
It led to that really weird--
- My first marriage.
(chuckles)
- That really weird first marriage, no.
(Link chuckles)
That really weird speech that you gave
when you tried to get elected.
- That really weird speech I
gave at my rehearsal dinner.
- Yes.
- That really weird speech
I gave at my 40th birthday party.
- Yes.
- That really weird speech
I gave every time I had to give a speech.
- But think of all the moments
that you haven't thought.
And how great it's gone.
- Yeah and how little work went into it.
- You know, Link, that's
why I'm here. (chuckles)
- Yeah.
- I'll do the thinking.
No, no, but you know what,
Stevie actually told me
the other day, she was
talking about, you know,
we have a lot of people
come in to our office
and meet with us for various things.
Potential projects, et
cetera, and she was telling me
when we went--
- I hope this ends
in a compliment.
- Premiere the other night.
She was like, you know,
Link is, he's so good
in those meetings, the way he's,
when it feels like things
are getting awkward
and they're saying something,
he says something to loosen it up and--
- Ah.
- You know.
- She didn't tell me that.
- And--
- She didn't want me to like
start to get flamey pants.
Like whoa look at my pants on fire.
- Flamey pants, okay.
See--
- Like try too hard.
- Right, you didn't think about it.
- I'm setting my pants on fire
because there's an awkward moment.
Because Stevie told me I'm good at this!
- And so--
- Yeah.
- But you're not sitting around
and calculating your strategy.
You're just like, they said something
and you're just saying the first thing
that comes to your mind.
- Yeah, I got that from my dad.
- Can't you translate
that into, first of all,
let me just say that this
is a little bit risky, okay?
It's a little bit risky.
But I think if you're--
- Yeah, I'm gonna be posting
like social security numbers
and like credit card numbers
and home addresses.
That's what I'm--
- But I think there's a way
to do it--
- Can I post and it goes
to somebody that then they say yes
and they let it go through
or not, like an operator?
- We could probably arrange that.
- There's somebody in
Instagram who's gonna be like,
you're about to do something stupid.
- We could probably
arrange that here in house.
- Don't give this man a
knife kind of a thing.
- We could probably do that here in house.
But I don't think we have to.
I think the way that you
do it is I think that
your Instagram is Link
unfiltered, first of all--
- I can't use filters?
(Rhett chuckles)
You thought that was funny.
- Everything has to be--
- I didn't think that was funny.
- Hashtag no filter.
But your initial instinct
is like I'm not gonna think
about this, I'm just gonna create it.
And then that moment before you post,
if I'm present or if your wife is present
or if one of your children is, no,
your children are probably gonna say--
- Just give me some
questions to ask myself.
I don't wanna have to be babysat.
- No no.
- So just give me
a couple questions--
- No I'm saying--
- Is there a social
security number visible?
- I was gonna say if you were alone--
- Okay yeah.
- If you're alone--
- Let's do that.
- Just stop and look at it--
- I'm a big boy.
- And be like okay.
Don't let the filter operate
until you've created the post.
- Oh.
- You don't need to pre-filter
things 'cause that's when
you're getting in your
head and you're locking up.
Not just follow your instincts
but then, you know what,
you have a chance, after
you've written everything
to be like, is this a good idea?
And at that point, the only reason
you shouldn't post
something is if you think,
oh, I didn't think about this.
This could be offensive in this way.
- Yes.
- Or so if it's gonna be
offensive in some way--
- Or you can see my nut sack.
- Exactly, you don't want any nut sack.
Not even a little bit of nut sack--
- Right.
- Should make it into the picture.
Instagram will allow a little
nut, just a little nut sack.
- A little peek of the sack.
- Yeah.
So no nut sack, no female nipples,
all the male nipples you want.
- Okay.
- And--
- Got two.
- And so, I just think you
gotta take the filter off
and just be like, this is a--
- I take pictures.
- This is an arena of self-expression.
That was another thing
that I wanna talk about.
Don't see it as work
that has to be judged.
The great thing is is that
it doesn't matter how active
and successful our Instagram accounts are
because thankfully we've
got this thing going
as the two of us that is
very well taken care of,
and actually not personally
managed by the two of us
so that it's actually active, right?
And so that's what supports us.
That's why we're able to sit
here and have this conversation
in this building.
Our livelihood is not
dependent on people's reaction
to your Instagram so you
shouldn't really worry.
Don't think of it as work.
Work is what you do to make a living.
- You're saying dance
like no one's watching.
- Dance like nobody's
watching but then know
that every once in awhile,
people are watching.
- Should I treat it as a personal account?
- And every once in awhile
people might be able
to see your nut sack and those times,
stop dancing and delete the post.
- What if I treat it that
only my mom is watching
because then there won't be any nut sack.
That'd be weird.
No social security numbers
'cause I don't want her
to have that.
- No but I don't think
you should see your mom
as your audience because I think
that would be a very narrow--
- All my stories would start with hey Mom.
- (chuckles) Yeah.
- I mean that would be
a comedic choice but--
- It would be.
- Again that may be
trying too hard.
- And you know what,
there's probably a comedian
who's done it already.
- Oh.
- I mean it's like the
Vlogbrothers deciding
to talk to each other.
- Should I not read the comments and likes
and track my following?
Just say caution to the,
it's not about the results.
- You know what, if you feel
like you would then begin
to associate your self-worth
with the reception
of your content, don't worry about that.
Don't look at the likes,
don't look at your followers.
Now, you might need to look
at the comments, again,
to make sure there's, 'cause
people will usually say like,
"Nut sack!"
If they see it.
- Okay.
- But other than that, I wouldn't
worry about the comments.
- I think the other component
is, to make it more fun,
there's also, who do I
follow so that I'm drawn
to the app as a user?
'Cause I do think once
I'm in it, then I'm like,
oh I'm also gonna post something.
- Well I think you need to,
I have some recommendations.
- Give 'em to me because I'm pretty sure
that I don't wanna follow
anyone that could be seen
as a peer in the industry or like--
- That's gonna be weird.
- Stretched as a competitor.
I just don't wanna watch
other YouTubers because
it's gonna seem like, oh,
I need to be doing what they're doing.
- Okay.
- You can be an exception
'cause you're also a friend.
- I'm gonna just say it is
gonna be a little bit weird
if it's like Link doesn't
follow anybody who does
what he does which is
usually what people do
because it's actually
informative to be part
of the community but if that's--
- I'm dancing and no one's watching.
- The goal here is to get you on Instagram
so if that's the way you feel about it,
then I'm not gonna argue with you.
I was gonna say, some people may be
a little weirded out by it.
- But that's what they think
and it's not about what they think.
- Okay, also, Instagram is
smart and knows who you look at
and sends you those posts so,
you could also follow those
people for the public facing,
you know, value of it and
then just not engage with them
and Instagram will stop
showing them to you.
I think, I don't know, AI.
- Who should I follow?
And don't give me any YouTubers.
- I'm not gonna give you very much at all.
I'm gonna give you just
a very small sample
of the kinds of accounts that
I find the most inspiration.
- 'Cause I know what I follow on Reddit.
I follow like people
peeling stuff off of things.
Dachshunds.
Perfect loops.
- Okay well, I think these
are the same types of things.
The things I enjoy most
like, I've shown you stuff
from this before.
KookSlams.
- Kook, K-O-O-K, slams.
- Kook, hopefully it's
not a derogatory term
for something else but--
- It's a bad surfer.
- It's a bad surfer is what I know it as
and in the context of this
account that's what it means.
So this is just people who've
had accidents in the ocean.
- Oh gosh.
- And it's just a series of people just
screwing their lives up
in the ocean, you know?
This is a good one, so this
is a beach front wedding.
- Oh goodness.
There's a little backdrop.
(girl screams)
- And there it is.
- Couldn't they know that the
ocean was going to come in
and crash on everything?
Isn't that something that the ocean does?
- The people are still sitting there.
So I mean, that entertained me.
I'm into that.
I wanted to see that.
- I also feel smarter than them.
- I'll lean over to my wife
and say, "Check this out.
"This wedding that just
got rampaged by a wave."
- You just been KookSlammed.
All right.
- Here's another one.
Similar theme, JerryOfTheDay.
A Jerry is a derogatory
term for a bad skier.
- Oh gosh, okay.
- A skier who doesn't know what's up,
is making bad decisions on the slopes.
So this is anybody who's just kind
of embarrassing themselves in general.
I don't know, I'll just
click on a random one here.
You know, this guy.
- This guy's skiing down.
He's hitting the jump, whoop.
He hits the jump and then hits,
plants his face.
(Rhett laughs)
- It ends in the perfect place, right?
The loop ends in the right
place, and that's it.
- Skis come off, nose
goes into the snow, okay.
- You get that little dopamine rush.
- So I've got the snow
and I got the ocean.
Your outdoor activities.
- Now but this is one
that I found recently
that I'm very excited
about, CatatonicYouths.
Only 10.7 thousand followers.
- Ooh, getting in early.
- And this is just this
person who has curated
all of these weird musicians,
like check this out.
♪ He's going to Malibu ♪
♪ And I said what about you ♪
♪ And what about the 'Bu ♪
♪ You know I came here for the day ♪
♪ Now I just can't seem to get away ♪
- Oh my gosh, this is horrible.
♪ I said what about you ♪
♪ What about the 'Bu ♪
♪ Said what about Malibu ♪
This is a joke.
- It's not.
It's not a joke, it's not a joke.
- Oh wow.
- And I'm gonna show you,
check this one out.
♪ Puff puff give ♪
- Puff puff give?
- Okay.
♪ It's not the earth I can't hurt ♪
- They're not in Malibu,
they're a little north
in San Francisco or San Fran
as I call it on my Instagram.
- This is even better.
These people in the forest.
♪ 'Cause I'm a warrior ♪
♪ How 'bout you ♪
♪ I'm a warrior ♪
♪ Earth warrior ♪
- I'm an Earth warrior.
- It's this band in the woods.
♪ Nature's soldier ♪
♪ Fighting for the earth ♪
(Rhett laughs)
- I'm a warrior,
nature's soldier, fighting for the earth.
That's a good cause too.
- Yeah it is great.
- Is it like a GoFundMe?
- And of course then you
got your meme accounts.
- CatatonicYouths.
- You got your meme accounts
like Daquan, you know, The Fat Jew.
- Okay.
These are funny.
Yeah, Christy shows me some of this stuff.
- That's what I'm clicking
on most of the time.
I mean but I also then
look into people's--
- What about dogs?
- I don't follow any dogs.
I probably should.
- I bet you there's lots of dogs--
- There's lots of dogs to follow.
You could follow just dogs.
You could follow just dogs,
that's how awesome it is.
- Okay.
- You're creating it.
It's like moving into, going
into a hotel in New York
and then looking across
the street and being able
to just digitally control
the different people
who live across from you.
- To open their shades.
- Yes.
- Well no.
They open the shade but then
you put your eyeballs on it.
Okay, I feel like I can
find, and you know what,
#EarBiscuits, you make
recommendations on Twitter
for what else I can follow on Instagram.
- I have to show you this.
This is when (chuckles)
Sting was at some awards show
and they were covering Fields of Gold.
- Yeah.
- Obviously,
it wasn't going well,
look at his reaction.
Oh no it's Every Step You Take.
(acoustic music)
- Oh my goodness.
♪ Every night you stay ♪
♪ I'll be watching you ♪
(Rhett laughs loudly)
- He's like trying.
He's trying to stomach it.
(both laughing)
This is great.
Now that's CatatonicYouths as well.
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
- So its just bad singing.
- (grunting) The solo, he did the solo.
Look at Sting's face, man!
- He's literally shaking
his head a little bit.
- (sighs) And this is endless.
It just keeps going.
There's so many people who make bad music
and I never knew I loved it so much.
- Wow.
- It's just endless.
Look.
Hours, Link, hours of wasting your time.
- I didn't even know,
see what I've missed.
- Now I will say, the one
thing we haven't discussed
is just the time suck and
pitfall and just kind of
generally dopamine expending exercise
that all social media is.
- Well, I've got a
Reddit pocket and I think
that I would just give some
of that to my Instagram
but I just don't think I
would be on it constantly.
- You gotta ration it.
- I mean I think
if I were gonna be on
Instagram constantly,
I would already have
been on Reddit constantly
given how much I enjoy that.
So I think I'm pretty good
at compartmentalizing.
And again, that may be
the fatal flaw in me
actually being on there.
But I'm getting closer to saying
I'm ready to do this but--
- Well I have an idea for your first post
which I think--
- Yeah we just have to think--
- I have an idea that I think will,
actually in a weird way,
addresses all your concerns.
- Okay.
- I think that, I don't think
that you're gonna be able
to do this if you don't embrace
posting pictures of yourself.
I think that the picture
you come back with
does need to be of yourself,
of your face, okay?
- Oh gosh.
- I think you need to
come back with a selfie.
- Come back with a--
- I think you need
to come back with a selfie
because you gotta come out
a little bit hot, man, and
overcoming this and not caring.
Hold on!
- I don't want people to think I'm hot.
Come out hot.
- And I think that
you need to have a real booger.
(Link sputters)
A real actual booger
sticking out of your nose.
- This is bad.
This is a bad idea because
it takes both of the problems
that I have with Instagram--
- No it doesn't.
- And it puts 'em both front and center.
Hey--
- No it disarms
the whole thing.
- Look at my face
and I think it's funny
that I'm doing this.
- We've been through this!
You are funny!
Okay?
You made a living being funny!
You are funny, get over it!
- Why not just make a fart joke?
I mean a booger joke?
- You can't see a fart, man.
(chuckles) You can't see a fart
and you shouldn't show a turd.
- Well you know what,
I'm gonna prove you wrong.
I have an idea.
- Okay.
- I have my own idea.
- That doesn't have to be
the idea because we talked
about how you don't need
to think about it but I just
think that if you come out
of the gate with something that
is a little self-deprecating
and it just embraces, don't
not show your face though.
I think at least, in the first 10 posts,
you gotta show your face.
- 10 times?
- In the first 10 posts
there needs to be you
showing your face once
is what I'm saying.
- I've got an idea.
- Okay.
But now you're thinking about it.
- That's true.
- You know what I shouldn't tell you--
- But it's the first one.
- You know what--
- I've thought about, I've got--
- Don't even think about the time
and don't even think about the content.
It's just when it hits
you, do it and don't care.
Don't use my idea, don't use my idea.
- I won't--
- Don't use an idea.
Have an idea and the idea being
formed is the post itself.
Happens in one swift motion.
- You know what, it's been very helpful
having this conversation
and I think I'm ready.
And I'm not gonna ask you
to go over to Instagram
and follow LinkLamont, which
no, is not my real name.
- There's another thing we didn't discuss,
but that's cool.
- Should I start over?
I got half a million
followers, I can't start over.
- Don't start over, go with that.
That's your social media name, man.
- When I reach a million followers,
I will make my first post back.
Just joking, not about that.
This is a form of self-expression.
I'm dancing like no one's watching.
- Is this photo--
- LinkLamont.
- Is the post going be--
- Follow or don't.
- Is the post going to be up
when this podcast is live?
- Yeah.
I'll make a commitment, I think I'm ready.
I think I'm, yes.
- When the video is live or
when the audio version's live?
- When this thing comes
out, that's the audio.
- Okay.
- By the time this comes out, it's there.
I'm excited, man.
I don't know if I'm gonna follow you but--
- I don't know if I'm gonna follow you.
- I mean I do follow you now
but that hasn't meant anything.
- (chuckles) Right.
You may have to unfollow
dancing like nobody's watching.
- Yeah.
- That's what I'm gonna call it.
- I think I need to--
- That's gonna center me.
- I think I need to follow it just in case
there is a nut sack and I might--
- I could just show it to you
right now if you wanna see it.
(Rhett chuckles)
- I might need to catch
the public nut sack.
Just in case there's a square of nut sack.
- A square?
- I don't know what kind
of underwear you got on.
Might have a square hole in it.
(both chuckle)
- Oh, it doesn't.
- Good.
- It doesn't.
All right thanks for hearing me out.
I don't know if this is
helpful for anybody else.
- Yeah everybody's like
what are you talking about?
I'm already on Instagram.
Now you've made me overthink it.
- All right but like I said, #EarBiscuits,
let me know what you think.
Commiserate with me if you're...
Don't talk me out of it because
by the time this comes out,
I've already made the
decision to be in on it.
You heard it, I just made it.
- Right just follow.
- But if you wanna recommend
something that you think
I would actually enjoy on Instagram,
please do that on Twitter, ironically.
Well I guess you could do it on Instagram.
- Yeah that's what I would suggest.
In the comments of your first post.
- Well I'll be damn.
- They should just recommend--
- Isn't that crazy?
- Accounts, yeah.
- Use #EarBiscuits, that
still works on Instagram,
doesn't it?
I believe it does.
- It does, it does.
- Do it and thank you for,
just thank you for sitting in on this.
I don't know, you know.
I'm a verbal processor
and I just need the space
to figure things out and I
couldn't do it without you.
Thank you for your help, Rhett.
- Anytime.
Anytime you wanna--
- I really appreciate it.
- You wanna monetize
advice from me, I'm here.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)